j'hésite pas maintenant a
commencé ma phrase par cet effet de
surprise en disant voilà on me dit
quelque chose il a
[Musique]
c'est vrai j'ai 54 ans un peu moins dans
ma tête je peux être encore très gamin
heureusement d'ailleurs
était stagiaire à tf1 ça remonte aux
années
fin des années 80 j'ai fait un stage
alors que j'étais étudiant en éducation
physique à la fac de caen
mais je ne suis corrompu par personne en
tout cas je l'espère et pas plus par
moundir que par qui que ce soit d'autre
comment dire une chose comme ça sachant
que je n'ai absolument pas d'équilibré
que ce serait pour moi la pire des
épreuves avec le passage d'une poutre
puis j'ai un petit problème de vertiges
et d'oreille interne donc debout sur un
tout petit poteau pour moi ce serait
vraiment un calvaire
effectivement j'ai une technique
pour éviter de voir les auréoles sous
les chemises quand il fait 45 degrés et
pour la petite histoire au départ
c'était des serviettes hygiéniques que
l'on collé et puis ensuite on a
progressé effectivement on a une idée
des patchs anti transpiration
c'est vrai il s'appelle yann le gac il
est le père fouras dans fort boyard et
c'est un type aux mille vies
c'est faux claude et theora s'entendent
bien s'apprécie se respecte et savent
qu'ils sont de formidables compétiteurs
claude détenteur du plus grand nombre de
victoires en individuel avec comme
dauphin theora
dijonnais et fier de l'être vive la
bourgogne libre
c'est faux j'ai le permis de conduire
auto moto bateau
j'aimerais vous dire oui je ne le sais
pas en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on l'a empêché de la tuer donc au
moment où mohamed a voulu en faire un
méchoui
elle est restée bien vivante et
heureusement
ah c'est faux quelle tristesse pour moi
c'était un des buts de ma vie j'ai
quatre enfants un grand garçon dimitri
21 ans des jumelles lily et violet de 16
ans et puis ma petite dernière dit ma
petite dernière mais c'est la plus
grande en taille de mes filles qui a 14
ans et qui s'appelle blanche
c'est presque vrai j'ai envie de vous
dire que les seuls produits proposés ce
sont tout ce qui concerne l'hygiène
intime des femmes
ah c'est faux mon premier prénom c'est
denis mon deuxième prénom c'est celui de
mon pas un jean-michel je suis pas le
plus fier de mes prénom je me fais bien
chambrer par mes enfants qui trouvent
que mes prénoms sont pas terribles je
suis assez d'accord avec eux mais bon on
se refait pas
ah non pas du tout moi j'aime pas en
paille et des animaux mais en revanche
ma femme c'est son métier
j'adore twitté parce que c'est le
premier réseau social que j'ai utilisé
parce que j'aime jouer avec les mots
j'aime écrire j'aime répondre j'aime
donner mon point de vue dans certaines
dans certains cas
l'instigateur je dirais pas alors j'ai
dû effectivement dire plusieurs fois à
mai au départ tout
commence avec un clip réalisé par un
internaute assez drôle avec des extraits
d'une saison de koh lanta entrecoupés de
ceux à saccader et ça a été vu par
plusieurs dizaines de millions de gens
et donc c'est devenu quelque chose un
gimmick un même
je sais pas c'est formidable de déjà sur
le podium c'est qui le premier
bond à écouter très bien vous le
saluerai de ma part voilà mais en tout
cas c'est j'ai bien fait de venir
répondre aux questions de brut
ma c'est tout le contraire je fais
beaucoup de sport cinq à six fois par
semaine je suis un boulimique de sport
j'en ai besoin pour mon équilibre
physique psychologique
faut être prêt à temps pour dire ça mais
en tout cas je crois que koh lanta a
bien aider les français à s'évader
virtuellement grâce à ses magnifiques
images du bout du monde lorsque tout le
monde était confinée à la maison et
c'est pas moi c'est le programme c'est
koh lanta
je pense que dès l'instant qu'on pense
avoir l'immunité avis quel que soit le
domaine c'est que on est sur la pente
descendante et que on a passé les
meilleurs moment donc il faut être
lucide personnel à l'immunité à vis ma
sentence est irrévocable